[Music]
so daily architecture or weekly
architecture just schedule wise
seems like you rarely schedule certain
types of things before noon your time
could you speak to
speak to that and perhaps just tell the
genesis story like how and when did you
begin doing that because that's
contraindicated if you're doing 80 hour
weeks right so there's a there was a
transition yeah of course that didn't
really become a possibility until i was
i was self-employed and i think i
started practicing it
originally when i was writing finding
ultra because i needed i needed quiet
hours before work began to just be
focused on that important thing
and i've just built upon it from there
so essentially i'm early to bed early to
rise i go to bed like around nine
and i generally get up around
sort of five five between five and six
and the early hours are are really
protected as
my own time so
morning meditation
journaling
creative projects no meetings no phone
calls like certainly like we're doing
this podcast this morning so i'll make
exceptions like we're doing this in the
morning but as a general rule i try not
to commit to anything outside of those
practices
for that initial phase of the day and so
after i finish those practices then i i
do my training in the morning
and i try to get that done before i go
into the work day
how
frequently would you say you succeed
if you
and i'm not to ever expect it to be a
hundred percent i'm just curious
what you would say it looks like and
when you get something because we were
talking about the death by a thousand
cuts earlier when you get really
tempting stuff
what do you do right like sometimes you
make exceptions but if you if you made
all the exceptions then the schedule
wouldn't work right because i'm sure you
have people right stuff earlier in the
day so so what's your what would you say
your hit rate is
and
how do you contend with the
the temptations
i would say outside of situations where
i'm traveling my hit rate's about 85
so that's high i'm pretty good yeah and
also
the people that i generally work with
like all know this now so it's less
often that i'm asked to do things during
those hours because like because they
know
and i've gotten much better at just just
not agreeing to do stuff
uh conference calls zoom calls and stuff
like that during that period of time but
if somebody's in you know the uk or in a
you know a very a radically different
time zone like there's situations where
it's like okay am i gonna be the huge
pain in the ass or am i gonna just make
an exception
you know so make them do the zoom call
at 11 pm yeah yeah like
i'm too much of a people pleaser for
that and that's the war that i'm always
waging like the healthy boundary versus
like the desire to be liked is is like
the battleground in my head and so
i'm pretty good about that the death by
a thousand cuts shows up in in other
areas of my life particularly like
regarding stuff that
isn't due or isn't going to happen for a
long period of time like if it's far
enough out on the calendar i'll pretty
much agree to anything
and
you know and then and then that day
arrives and you're like what am i doing
i'm never doing this again and then the
following week you're you know reaping
the same thing so
i you know that's
that's like my mount everest right now
and listen these are these are problems
of of abundance they're the result of of
you know working very hard to create
something that is interesting to people
and so you get offered cool stuff and i
want to take advantage of all the cool
stuff like i know what it's like to
not have people interested in having me
involved in cool stuff
but at what cost right and yeah and it's
really hard to do that it's like do you
want to go do this amazing thing you're
like 100 i do
but
what are you really trying to accomplish
where is your focus you know vested
and calibrating those opportunities
against the things that are most
important in your life and you know i
have four kids like i have you know i
have other responsibilities outside of
my professional responsibilities that
are important to me so
i'm not always great at making those
decisions but i think i'd like to think
i'm getting a little bit better
you